which comedy legend's crotch jokes
inspired melissa roush's career keep
watching to discover how this talented
performer landed her big break as
bernadette on the big bang theory when
melissa roush made her first appearance
as howard's blind date bernadette on
cbs's the big bang theory in 2009 it
didn't seem likely she'd be coming back
the pair hardly hit it off with howard
offering crude jokes and questions about
her interests and bernadette
indifferently swatting each one away but
then at dinner they suddenly bonded over
their meddling mothers a spark was
kindled and a recurring role was born
shocked viewers realized the graceless
howard had finally found his perfect
match and the romance which would lead
to marriage in season 5 came as a
surprise to roush 2 telling backstage
magazine i was so grateful when big bang
happened i was supposed to be a one-time
guest star landing a hit series was a
major accomplishment for the
up-and-coming actress but it didn't
happen overnight roush was just a kid
when she got hooked on comedy that's
when she started working toward her
chosen career and began developing the
character that would one day get her a
big break as bernadette hey
it's a good thing you did that you would
have regretted it your whole life your
whole life feels good don't it feels
good from her first awkward car ride
with howard roush created a character
that set bernadette apart as smart cute
and quick-witted but if there's one
trait fans can't forget about her it's
her chirpy childish voice which she
modeled after her mother rausch told
insider my mother sounds very similar to
bernadette she's got a very high pitched
voice except with a new jersey accent
and i grew up imitating her roush also
mimicked stars she saw on tv like whoopi
goldberg and don knotts it was a great
way to overcome her natural shyness at
school but it didn't always work out as
planned telling roger ebert.com i would
memorize stand-up sets that weren't my
own which i didn't realize was not
allowed since i was seven years old they
were actually really inappropriate for a
kid my age in one instance roush
memorized a set from a whoopi goldberg
hbo special that had a lot of f-bombs
the teacher ended up calling roush's mom
about how roush went from being shy and
barely talking one minute to using very
inappropriate language the next whoopi
goldberg had this character where she
was like pointing at her crotch and
being like over here as roush got older
her interest in performing comedy and
getting on stage grew stronger she also
found more appropriate outlets to
express herself she spent most of her
free time doing community theater
attending theater camp and making up
shows in her basement with her brother
ben raised jewish it made sense that
roush even had a comedy club themed bat
mitzvah when she was a young teen roush
couldn't remember a time when she didn't
want to be an actress throughout her
childhood the adults around her
supported and guided her toward her
dreams telling inside jersey i went to
brookdale arts camp for my entire
childhood and had a fantastic theater
counselor there who gave me some of my
first comedic sketches to do i also had
a terrific theater teacher at marlboro
high school who taught me a great deal
and was very encouraging without that
support she might not have taken the
next steps toward her future success
after graduating high school roush went
to marymount manhattan college to study
acting she encountered great teachers
there and one in particular helped her
with voice work so her new jersey accent
wouldn't be quite so strong others
taught her how to build on her natural
ability to create characters but roush
knew she had to do even more to grow as
a performer by that point she'd realized
that comedians write their own material
so she began performing her stand-up
sets in new york city clubs telling
roger ebert.com i did stand up for about
10 years in new york and i was one of
those comedians who started out just
handing out flyers on the street in the
freezing cold to get people to come see
comedy in order to get stage time i
would love to eventually go back to it i
grew up being such a huge fan of comedy
and stand-up as if she wasn't working
hard enough roush also started writing
with college friend winston bygoal who
she met freshman year beigel came to
watch her set and they decided to write
some sketches together because they had
a very similar sensibility and their
favorite thing to do was make each other
laugh but even with all that training
and effort her professional career
seemed stuck in neutral after she'd
graduated telling inside jersey i don't
think people knew what to do with me i'd
have people say maybe i should dye my
hair lose weight gain weight it was
never a specific box you could check it
was just yeah sorry not my cup of tea
and of course i was really green too i'd
go out for parts in cargo pants and a
jean jacket without any makeup roush did
land some gigs and she was excited to be
part of the vh1 series best week ever
but she needed her big break roush
already knew how to write a stand-up set
so she started writing solo shows
wherever she could from burger joints to
laundromats telling inside jersey just
knowing i could do that at night made it
easier waiting tables all day she was
still riding with beigel who she was
dating and would soon marry when they
got the idea to write a one-woman show
together it started as a not very funny
autobiographical story about trying to
make it after college but then they were
inspired by jenna bush hagar who was
around rausch's age and about to start
teaching at a charter school rausch told
interview magazine so we decided to
combine the two the one woman show that
we were writing for me with this idea of
making it through jenna bush's voice and
exploring the bush presidency through
her eyes we called it the miseducation
of jenna bush and it was a way to do
this coming of age story a young woman
coming into her adulthood while also
using the bush presidency for some
comedic exploration the show was a hit
it earned awards at comedy festivals and
roush's performance caught the eye of an
agent the time seemed right to move to
la even then though roush had to hit
rock bottom before she could finally
rise to the top of her game telling
entertainment tonight i was at the
unemployment office the day before i got
the audition for the big bang theory i
was doing a lot of driving around crying
in my car i was just in that out-of-work
actor grind thankfully roush nailed the
audition and wound up with much more
than a guest spot after a lifetime of
dreaming and working she'd secured her
spot in hollywood
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite big bang theory stars are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]